by 1868 London was the center of the
largest empire the world had ever known
the city attracted the greatest thinkers
from all parts of the world each an ally
who will help you fight against
exploitation Alexander Graham Bell
Scottish inventor and engineer inspired
by the deafness of loved ones he studied
acoustics and was one of the early
inventors of the telephone and other
modern marvels I've been working in
something it's meant to stun an
assailant it's a blessing that you
employ your genius for the common good
Alec Karl Marx the author of the
communist manifesto in his writing and
in speeches spent his life fighting for
the rights of workers challenge you both
to help those who really need your
assistance the working people they
accept should we at least talk about
these things for
saadat we accept Charles Darwin father
the theory of evolution his ideas defied
popular thinking about the origin of
species I am used to people challenging
my ideas in fact I live for it lately
however attacks have taken a darker turn
Charles Dickens in Oliver Twist and
other tales the novelist highlighted the
plight the poor opening the eyes of the
city's inhabitants to the deprivation
around them here we are in the world's
most advanced city yet its citizens he
themselves vulnerable to charlatans is
there a doctor nearby bring her inside
Florence Nightingale provision took
nursing out of the home and turned it
into a profession and set the standard
for modern healthcare Queen Victoria
came to embody the century she was known
as the grandmother of Europe your
majesty and her 64 year reign saw the
entire century dubbed the Victorian era
I call upon you to foil this treacherous
plot now it's your turn to make history
discover the secrets behind London's
greatest men and women
the work begins immediately will you
join us
not every problem can be solved by
blowing things sky high was the phone in
that pre-order now at amazon access to
the Darwin and Dickens conspiracy
reserve now available october twenty
third